hey it's me Peter from what if listen
we're on the hunt for a talented
individual to join us as a social media
Community engagement specialist here at
our company underknown and this isn't
just any job it's your chance to be at
the heart of what makes our shows
special imagine being the Maestro of
vibrant online communities where your
creativity and ability to engage an
audience brings our shows to life beyond
the screen from handcrafting unique
content to hosting virtual events you'll
be the one sparking the conversations
that'll turn our shows into shared
experiences experiences that don't just
entertain people but also Inspire inform
unite them look this is your opportunity
to be part of something big to connect
with engage grow communities who share
our your passion for the wondrous World
of Science and Discovery this is your
moment to shine go to the link in the
comments and create a short video no
longer than 2 minutes showing us why
you're the perfect fit for this role